the U.S housing market is entering a
dire situation if we go back before the
covid pandemic the housing market looked
normal once the pandemic hit all of a
sudden the government and central banks
flooded the financial Market with cheap
Capital when cheap capitals available
people run and they start borrowing and
that led to an absolute Bonanza in the
U.S housing market but now we are on the
other end of the spectrum as the Federal
Reserve continues to tighten Financial
conditions and Destroy demand we are
seeing mortgage applications fall off a
cliff as we can see when mortgage
applications fall off a cliff U.S
mortgage lenders start to go broke as
pointed out in Bloomberg this week
according to Nancy Wallace the chair of
the Real Estate Group at Berkeley Haas
the non-banks are poorly capitalized
when the mortgage Market tanks they are
in trouble and here you can see in this
graph from The Mortgage Bankers
Association that mortgage Market is
slowing down in a drastic way and as
Bloomberg pointed out the lender whose
loans dropped to 85 five cents those
losses can be debilitating and on top of
that business is broadly plunging
overall mortgage application volume has
plunged by more than 50 percent this
year then if we take a look Charlie
balilo absolutely destroying the public
narrative stating that U.S housing
affordability is at its lowest level in
33 years below the July 2006 low which
was the peak of the last housing bubble
back then National home prices
subsequently fell 25 percent to their
low in December 2011. today the price
declines have just began then Charlie
pointed out that existing home sales
continue to plummet down 20 percent over
the last year and they are at their
lowest levels since June of 2020
following the same pattern as the last
housing bubble affordability collapses
sales plummet and then prices decline as
we know affordability is an important
part of the market But ultimately it's
not just affordability that's suffering
we are seeing a complete slowdown in the
U.S housing market but the scary part is
that we're actually at the beginning of
this crisis not at the end the Federal
Reserve is in control of financial
markets we've seen asset prices across
the world all fall in unison as the
Federal Reserve and other central banks
continue to destroy demand every
investor every homeowner and everyone in
the market looking for a home they
simply keep asking themselves when will
the FED wave the White Flag because
until the FED pivots expect a lot more
pain hey you did you like this video
great make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time